Big changes are happening this year in Germany.
Now, if you're wondering.
What changes am I talking about,
I'll let you know right now.
Tomorrow, 19 of January,
Buddhist tag is gonna vote
for the Germany's new citizenship law.
And if everything goes well under the plan,
by April, the dual citizenship will be effective.
Now, if you're wondering
what does it mean?
Many countries would have to give up
their own citizenship in order to get the German.
For example,
to bishop in Albania and so many other countries.
And if this gets approved,
then we get to keep both.
But it's not only that.
People that are well integrated
and they have C1 level in German,
they can apply for only three years
to have the German citizenship.
So yeah. That's amazing.
I don't know.
What do you think?
Let me know in the comments.